Donald Trump found some votes in Georgia
they just weren't the ones he was
looking for you know it's not every day
that the former president of the United
States gets charged with multiple
felonies or no I guess at this point it
is uh every day it seems like but a
Georgia grand jury indicted former
president Donald Trump charging him with
felony racketeering in several
conspiracy charges as part of a sweeping
investigation into his attempts to
overturn the 2020 election the 41 count
indictment also names 18 additional
defendants including League luminaries
like Sydney Powell Jenna Ellis John
Eastman Kenneth chisbro and Jeffrey
Clark also among the indicted is Rudy
Giuliani who himself pioneered the use
of Rico charges to go after the mob back
when he was U.S attorney this thing is
incredibly ironic well well well
how the turntables
so let's break down the Georgia
indictment and as a reminder the
indictment contains unproven allegations
just because the grand jury voted to
indict all that means is that they
believe that there was probable cause
that a crime may have been committed
that is a far cry from the standard of
Beyond a reasonable doubt that the
prosecutors will need to prove at trial
but the Fulton County indictment Echoes
the DCM Diamond by starting with the
premise of quote Trump and the other
defendants charged in this indictment
refused to accept that Trump lost and
they knowingly and willfully joined a
conspiracy to unlawfully change the
outcome of the election in favor of
Trump trump and 18 alleged
co-conspirators have been accused of 41
different counts now not all of the
co-defendants are accused of having
committed the same crimes from himself
has been accused of 13 of the 41 counts
more on that later count one is for
violating the Georgia RICO statute
basically the way that this indictment
is written is that the code event is
engaged in several different General
schemes in perpetration of 40 different
counts Each of which functions as a
predicate for count number one Rico but
let's start with the predicate offense
is that Trump is charged with committing
a predicate offense is a type of crime
that is related to another crime in this
case the big crime is racketeering in
violation of George's Rika statute and
to violate Rico a person must engage in
a pattern of racketeering activity then
not every crime can be a predicate crime
for Georgia Rico and the law lists 43
specific crimes that can qualify under
the law that can be used as a predicate
act but many potentially apply here
false statements and writings
impersonating a public officer forgery
filing false documents influencing
Witnesses computer theft computer
trespass computer invasion of privacy
and conspiracy to fraud the state and
acts of theft and perjury and in the
indictment prosecutors listed 161 acts
they say prove that a violation of the
RICO Act occurred among the acts include
things like accessing Dominion voting
machines and influencing Witnesses not
all the acts are crimes on their own and
the indictment cites several Trump
tweets for example and when asked
whether a tweet can be a crime Willa
said that the tweets are quote alleged
to be acts taken in furtherance of the
conspiracy
many occurred in Georgia
and some occurred in other jurisdictions
and are included because the grand jury
believes they were part of the illegal
effort to overturn the results of
Georgia's 2020 presidential election now
this is very similar to the rules
regarding normal Garden variety
conspiracies which we covered in the
context of the DC indictment crimes are
often made up of smaller non-criminal
acts buying a gun is legal buying a gun
as part of a criminal conspiracy to rob
a bank is illegal telling lies is legal
telling a lie as part of a conspiracy to
defraud someone is illegal but that's
how you get really dumb legal takes like
this tweet things that are apparently
illegal in America tweeting that you're
watching TV reserving rooms for meetings
asking someone for a phone number which
is not only a dumb legal take it was
actually stolen from somebody else but
at least it gave rise to one of the
greatest tweets from internet hippo new
right-wing thing is describing crimes as
generically as possible to pretend like
they're not crimes someone gets
convicted of conspiracy and they start
yelling wow so it's illegal to make
plans with friends now but it has both
crimes on their own and as predicates
for Rico the indictment alleges several
different schemes there are some
similarities with the various schemes
with the DC indictment but there are
also differences the first is the fake
electors plot the indictment alleges
that co-defendant Mike Roman who worked
for the Trump 2020 campaign as director
of election day operations helped
organize slates of phony Trump electors
purporting to represent the electoral
votes from Battleground States including
Georgia on November 30th 2020 Roman
instructed an unindicted co-conspirator
to quote coordinate with the individuals
associated with the Trump campaign to
contact state legislators in Georgia and
Elsewhere on behalf of Donald Trump and
to encourage them to unlawfully appoint
presidential electors from their
respective States this allegation shows
that the effort to send false
certificates to Nara and Congress was
highly coordinated by people connected
to Trump on December 3rd 2020 Giuliani
Ellis Stallings and Eastman met with
members of the Georgia Senate who were
present at a Senate Judiciary
subcommittee meeting and solicited them
to violate their Oaths of office by
unlawfully appointing presidential
electors from Georgia during the hearing
Giuliani made two false representations
that at least 96 600 imbalance were
counted in the November 3rd 2020
presidential election in Georgia despite
there being no record of those ballots
having been returned to a County
elections office and that Dominion
voting systems equipment used in the
November 3rd 2020 presidential election
in Antrim County Michigan this daily
recorded 6 000 votes for Joseph R Biden
when the votes were actually cast for
Donald John Trump during the hearing
defendant Ray Smith in Atlanta lawyer
made six misrepresentations about
election fraud such as claims that 66
248 underage people illegally registered
to vote before their 17th birthday while
Trump was tweeting Ken chisbro was
organizing the fake electors in
Battleground States on her about the
11th day of December 2020 he sent an
email with attached documents to Mike
Roman the documents were to be used by
Trump presidential elected nominees in
Georgia for the purpose of casting
electoral votes for Trump despite the
fact that Trump lost Georgia defendant
James Schaefer who was then the chairman
of the Georgia Republican party oversaw
a December 2020 meeting at the state
capitol of 16 GOP electors who signed
documents falsely claiming Trump won
Schaefer and several other defendants
created document entitled certificate of
the votes of the 2020 electors from
Georgia with knowledge that said
document contained the false statement
we the undersigned being the duly
elected and qualified electors for
President and Vice President of the
United States of America from the state
of Georgia do hereby certify the
following Trump and his co-defendants
included the fake certificate in a legal
filing and then there was the attempt to
call a special legislative session on
December 5th 2020 Trump called Governor
Brian Kemp and allegedly solicited
requested an import Tunes Camp to call a
special session of the Georgia General
Assembly oh so like we're not supposed
to importune people anymore I thought
this was America huh isn't America
sorry was America but on December 6 2020
Trump tweeted gee what a surprise has
anyone informed the so-called says he
has no power to do anything Governor
Brian Kemp and his puppet lieutenant
governor Jeff Duncan that they could
easily solve this mess and win signature
verification and call a special session
so easy on December 7th Trump called
speaker of the Georgia House of
Representatives David Ralston and asked
him to convene a special session of the
legislature for the purpose of
unlawfully appointing presidential
elections in Georgia prosecutors allege
that Trump was trying to coerce Ralston
Kemp and Miller into committing a felony
then there was the New Year's Eve
lawsuit Trump's campaign filed several
legal challenges in Georgia seeking to
throw at ballots or overturn the results
the indictment says that the New Year's
Eve lawsuit which was filed by John
Eastman included statements about Mass
fraud that Trump knew were false the
statements included the suggestion that
dead people underage people felons
unregistered voters and people with PO
Boxes illegally cast votes the lawsuit
demanded the Kemp in raffensberger
decertified the election results and
Trump signed a document verifying the
facts of the complaint were true to the
best of his knowledge then there was of
course the perfect phone call on January
2nd 2021 44 days after Biden was
declared the Victor in Georgia Trump
called Brad raffensberger and said quote
I just want to find
uh 11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state and flipping
the state is a great Testament to the
country I only need 11 000 votes the
indictment says attorney called Trump
made 13 false assertions about election
fraud in Georgia he told raffensberger
that quote the ballot said
that could find that they are
for them because you know what they did
and you're not reporting it that's a you
know that's a criminal that's a criminal
offense and and you know you can't let
that happen that's that's a big risk to
you and to Ryan your lawyer that's a big
risk grafensburg's lawyer Ryan Germany
told Trump that raffensberger didn't
have the legal authority to conduct
another recount but Trump applied
pressure quote Brad what are we going to
do we won the election and it's not fair
to take it away from us like this
and it's going to be very costly in many
ways Trump followed up his call by
threatening raffensberger on social
media according to the indictment
Trump's scheme to overturn the election
continued at least until September 7th
2021 when he said raffensberger a letter
from Phil braffensberger the DeKalb
County had violated the proper chain of
custody procedures for 43 000 absentee
ballots quote I would respectfully
request that your department checked
this and if true along with many other
claims of voter fraud and voter
irregularities start the process of
decertifying the election or whatever
the correct legal remedy is and announce
the true winner as stated to you
previously the number of false and or
irregular votes is far greater than
needed to change the Georgia election
result now as you can probably already
tell Trump and his co-defense are going
to need a good lawyer if you need a
great lawyer my firm the eagle team can
help if you or a loved one has suffered
from cancer suffered an injury or death
in the family or were involved in a car
crash we can represent you or help find
you the right attorney just click on the
link in the description for a free
consultation with my team because you
don't just need a legal team you need
the eagle team the link is down below
now back to Trump and then there were
the computer hackers in Coffee County
one of the more bizarre sagas laid out
in this indictment is the story of how
Sydney Powell coordinated agents in
Coffee County Georgia to hack into
voting machines at the past of Powell
Kathleen Latham chairwoman of the Coffee
County GOP and Scott Hall in Atlanta
bail bondsman met with computer
forensics experts from Atlanta firm
Sullivan Stricker at the Coffee County
elections office once there the election
official Misty Hampton invited them in
and the conspirators allegedly and on
camera accessed the Coffee County voting
machines and in the words of Scott Hall
quote we scanned every freaking ballot
the indictment alleges that Latham and
the others were not authorized by the
election board to do this and that after
they imaged the voting machines they
then disseminated the secret voter data
from the servers at Sullivan Stricker to
other co-conspirators and then there was
the harassment of Ruby Freeman and her
daughter Shea Moss who were both
elections workers during the January
second conversation with raffensberger
Trump said that Freeman was a scammer
who was responsible for fraud originally
awarding at least eighteen thousand
ballots to Joseph art Biden at the State
Farm Arena and allegedly some of Trump's
co-defendants traveled from out of state
to harass Freeman intimidated her and to
solicit her to falsely confess to
election crimes that she did not commit
for example Stephen Lee a police
chaplain from Illinois tried to
intimidate Freeman by making a surprise
visit to Freeman's home in mid-December
2020. and as you can see on the video
the police body cam footage shows Lee
acknowledging that he had knocked on
Freeman's door and offered to provide a
pro bono service to her you may want to
let her know that you know I've got some
pro bono uh service for her afterwards
Lee allegedly asked Harrison Floyd to
arrange a meeting with Freeman to
discuss an immunity deal in exchange for
false admission of committing election
fraud and Floyd was the director of the
black voices for Trump so that takes us
to the predicate offenses the foregoing
summary is just the tip of the iceberg
here the diamond goes into much greater
detail about the ax that Trump and
others allegedly engaged and this video
would be feature length if I went into
the all the detail of the crimes that
the alleged facts but based on the
foregoing facts the code event is
accused of 41 different counts one of
the patterns that you see in this
indictment is that it alleges crimes
committed by the folks on the ground and
then the very next count is the crimes
that allegedly were committed by the
leaders of the conspiracy uh and the
ones who would sort of plan things out
and coordinated and Donald Trump in
particular is accused of committing 13
different crimes the first was the
solicitation of violation of an oath by
a public officer under Georgia Code
section 16-10-1 any public officer who
willfully and intentionally violates the
terms of his oath as prescribed by law
shall upon conviction be imprisoned
Georgia law requires public officials to
take an oath to quote support the
Constitution of the United States and of
the state of the governor Attorney
General Secretary of State and members
of the state legislator all took the
statutory oath upon assuming office and
Trump is accused of soliciting conducts
such as altering the results of an
election which arguably violates the
oath that raffensberger Ralston and
others swore Trump was also charged with
violating this section by sending
raffensberger a letter in September of
2021. then there was the conspiracy to
commit impersonating a public officer
under Georgia Code 16-10-23 a person who
falsely holds himself out as a peace
officer or other public officer or
employee with intended to mislead
another into believing that he is
actually such officer commits the
offensive impersonating an officer Trump
and the defendants unlawfully conspired
to cause certain individuals to falsely
hold themselves out as the duly elected
and qualified presidential electors from
the state of Georgia Trump and the
defendants are alleged to have
unlawfully conspired to cause certain
individual to falsely hold themselves
out as the duly elected and qualified
presidential electors from the state of
Georgia public officers with intent to
mislead the president of the United
States Senate the archivist of the
United States the Georgia Secretary of
State and the chief judge of the United
States district court for the Northern
District of Georgia into believing that
they actually were such officers then
there was the conspiracy to commit
forgery in the first degree in Georgia a
person commits the offense of first
degree forgery when with the intent of
fraud he or she knowingly makes altars
or possesses any writing other than a
check in a fictitious name or in such
manner that the writing as made or
altered purports to have been made by
another person at another time with
different Provisions or by authority of
one who did not give such Authority and
utters or deliver such writing here a
fake electors signed certificates
falsely certifying that they were duly
elected and qualified electors for the
President and Vice President of the
United States of America from the state
of Georgia when that was not true and
count 11 charges Trump with presenting
the fake certificate to the archivist of
the United States in Fulton County
Georgia then there was a conspiracy to
commit false statements and writings
false statement in writing is covered by
Georgia Code 16-10-20 which states that
any person who knowingly and willfully
falsifies conceals or covers up by any
trick scheme or device a material fact
makes a false fictitious or fraudulent
statement or representation or makes or
uses any false writing or document
knowing the same to contain any false
fictitious or fraudulent statement or
entry has committed a crime now this law
differs from the general charge of
making false statements in violation of
Georgia Code section
21-2-560 because it does not require an
oath and criminalizes any knowing and
willful false statements in any manner
within the jurisdiction of any state or
local department or agency now counts 13
and 19 relate to the fake electoral
certificate counts 29 and 39 are
connected to the raffensberger call
count 28 charges Mark Meadows in
addition to Trump for solicitation of
violation of Oath by a public officer
for the perfect phone call and fonnie
Willis could have charged the election
fraud version of this crime but that
crime isn't a RICO predicate which is
probably why the more General false
statements law was used here and then
there's the filing false documents
charged under Georgia Code
16-10-21 B Trump allegedly violated
these sections by attesting to the facts
in the New Year's Eve lawsuit and by
filing false elector certificates so now
that we've talked about all of the
predicate acts let's talk about
racketeering let's talk about what Trump
and Young Thug have in common and that
is a Georgia RICO charge some
commentators have had to fall on their
swords because this time it is Rico
fine
it's Rico
are you happy now now contrary to
popular belief just because something
might be a Ricoh violation on a federal
level or a state level that doesn't
necessarily mean that the crimes are
more serious or that the defendant faces
more jail time Rico first and foremost
was a tool created to deal with
especially difficult to convict criminal
Enterprises George's RICO law was
enacted in 1981 about a decade after the
original Federal RICO statute and the
Georgia RICO law was modeled on the
federal version which Congress enacted
to deal with Mafia bosses Rico allowed
prosecutors to tie mom bosses to the
actions of their underlings who carried
out the crimes on their behalf so Rico
was created not because it's more strict
but because it's easier to prove in
certain situations Rico can be a way for
a prosecutor to send a message like
conspiracy it allows you to bring in a
lot of evidence and other people that
might not otherwise be an explicit part
of the crime and sometimes this can be a
good thing and sometimes it can be a bad
thing in Georgia Rico cases tend to take
a really long time and takes lots of
resources which prosecutors can use as a
tool to strong-arm some defendants now
it's generally easier to convict some
one under George's Rika statue than it
is under the federal statute in part
it's because the law is expansive but
also has actual definitions now Federal
Rico is very complicated actually
litigated feral Rico before and federal
courts have adopted a very complicated
test the prosecutors often have a hard
time meeting but Georgia Court seemed to
skirt over this issue uh this is my
gloss of what needs to be proven but the
case law is fairly underdeveloped in
Georgia Georgia Code
16-14-4 B States it shall be unlawful
for any person employed by or associated
with any Enterprise to conduct or
participate indirectly or indirectly
such Enterprise through a pattern of
racketeering activity so in other words
a prosecutor has to prove an Enterprise
a pattern of activity and a racketeering
activity now the definition of
enterprise is extremely broad as defined
by the Georgia Code Enterprise means any
person sole proprietorship partnership
Corporation business trust Union
chartered under the laws of the state or
any other legal entity or any
unchartered Union Association or group
of individuals associated in fact
although not a legal entity and it
includes elicit as well as listen
Enterprises and governmental as well as
other entities now pattern of
racketeering activity means engaging in
at least two acts of racketeering
activity and furtherance of one or more
incidents schemes or transactions that
have the same or similar intense results
accomplices victims or methods of
commission or otherwise are interrelated
by distinguishing characteristics and
are not isolated incidents within a
four-year period and then finally
racketeering activity means to commit or
attempt to commit or to solicit course
or intimidate another person to commit
any crime which is chargeable by
indictment under the laws of the state
involving basically one of the 43 types
of enumerated crimes which we've already
talked about and of which there are a
lot alleged here now the Georgia
indictment lays out a pretty clear
Enterprise in fact it's the same
Enterprise someone running for
re-election from the government that was
basically at issue in a case called
Caldwell versus state that I'll talk
about in just a second and there are way
more than two insists of conduct alleged
in the indictment that could form a
pattern and finally a lot of the alleged
conduct could qualify as racketeering
activity as it fits within many of the
enumerated categories of the RICO statue
now Georgia courts have concluded that
at least one of the predicate acts for
the Ricoh charge must have been
committed in the county in which the
criminal proceeding is brought however
the RICO law lets the government
introduce evidence of crimes committed
outside of Georgia to prove that there
was a wider criminal conspiracy and
that's what the indictment alleges that
Trump and his allies operated to
criminal Enterprise in Fulton County but
also in other Georgia counties and other
swing States now the Georgia RICO Act
has been used in a wide variety of
different cases historically including
charging four people with running an
assisted suicide Network in violation of
state law it was used to prosecute
former DeKalb County Sheriff Sydney
Dorsey who was convicted of
masterminding the murder of his
successor who was fatally ambushed in
his driveway Dorsey was found guilty of
murder and racketeering after he
organized four men to kill his opponent
fawnee Willis used it to convict Atlanta
teachers in a test cheating scandal
involving 180 Educators and Willis is
currently pursuing several Rico cases
including a racketeering case against
Young Thug and several other rappers
affiliated with the alleged street gang
young slime life now the expansion of
Rico laws has had plenty of criticism
some people argue that the list of
predicate defenses is way too broad it
can also complicate a case by making it
more difficult to try and Trump will
likely argue that the law can't be used
against a political campaign however
there's precedent for using the Georgia
RICO Act for corrupt political campaign
Maneuvers in an early case called
Caldwell versus State the Supreme Court
of Georgia found that Rico applied to an
elective office holder seeking
re-election specifically the
commissioner of the Georgia Department
of Labor there Caldwell and 15 employees
of the Department of Labor maintained
control of the department through a
pattern of racketeering consisting of
alleged crimes related to The Campaign
proceeding the 1982 election including
theft by deception extortion false
statements and false swearing the Court
held that quote by its expressed terms
the RICO Act includes as a crime a
re-election campaign by the holder of
public office in which two or more
similar or inter related predicate
defenses specified in the ACT are
committed but there's still some
significant issues with parts of the
Georgia indictment well we talked about
how non-criminal acts can be overt acts
in furtherance of a conspiracy sometimes
non-criminal speech must always remain
non-criminal unlike the DC indictment
the Georgia indictment includes a lot of
activity that's core First Amendment
Free Speech even when you are engaged in
criminal conspiracy you still have the
right of free speech and the DC
indictment avoids almost all of that but
by including that kind of speech parts
of the Georgia indictment might be
thrown out on First Amendment grounds or
at least complicate things and some of
the alleged crimes seems to go after
core political activity as well for
instance asking legislators to appoint
electors now it's one thing to ask
public officials to do something that
they have no power to do or is illegal
to do but it's another to ask a
legislator to do something that they
might actually have the power to do that
could be considered core political
activity and that might not be colorable
as a crime and that could be a problem
with some of the charges that are
alleged here here but this is again a
quagmire that the DC indictment seemed
to avoid and for reasons that I don't
have time to go into there's also a
bunch of removal issues that might
result in part of the case ending up in
federal court now here all 19 defendants
were charged with felony racketeering
under George's Rico's statute which
carries a mandatory minimum sentence of
five years if convicted but those five
years can be probation but the president
of the United States does not have power
to pardon people for State convictions
so a future president couldn't get them
off the hook and the Georgia Governor
doesn't have the power either the
Georgia Board of paroles and pardons
only considers pardons for those who
have completed their full sense
obligation and have been free of
supervision and or criminal involvement
for at least five consecutive years
thereafter as well as five consecutive
years immediately prior to applying but
as you can tell there have been a lot of
recent indictments and the only way I've
been able to get through them all is
with a really good cup of coffee which
is what I get from today's sponsor Trade
coffee now seriously I'm gonna need a
lot of coffee to get through the next
couple of years of trump news I think we
all will but trade's great not only
because they have a huge selection of
your favorite coffees but they have a
fine-tuned matching process that helps
you discover fresh coffee based on your
taste preferences I have very specific
tastes in coffee basically I want
something that tastes like hot chocolate
and pairs well with milk and trade was
able to find me the perfect bean and
let's be honest you claim you want a
rich dark roast but you really want a
coffee milkshake and either way trade
has you covered and don't worry even
though we're in the middle of summer
they have a huge selection of cold brew
coffees as well we'll trade you can
discover new coffees from the nation's
top Roasters you can choose your coffee
rate it and your coffee suggestions get
even better with time all conveniently
delivered straight to your door it's
really the best coffee website out there
and if you already know what you like
then they probably already have your
preferred roaster in stock with a great
price so if you'd like to try Trade
coffee legal eaglets will get their
first bag free when they sign up all you
have to do is click on the link that's
in the description or the one that's on
screen right now and not only will you
get your first bag free but you'll also
get free shipping so to get your first
bag free and free shipping click on the
link that's down below after that click
on this link over here for more legally
eagle or I'll see you in court